hey reject nation Greg Aldi here John
we're gonna do a spoiler talk of ant-man
in the wasp I'm wearing a Batman shirt
why cuz freaking hot outside and this is
the most comfy shirt I could wear it's
over a hundred degrees sorry for where I
live in my mouth making a link for the
cockpit my shorts oh man they're gonna
bite your nuts don't let over yeah
that's gonna hurt and be funny at the
same time guys marbles in the background
look Marvel like that Marvel or Marvel
fan boys this video is off to a terrible
start at the time of this video being
uploaded we are probably stressing to
get to our live event at arena city
lounge 6 p.m. tonight people a lot of
fun man little had to stop at beer day
for a lot prepping movie pass accepted
couple tickets still available and buy a
couple I mean several fifty to you we're
not gonna do a full video breakdown with
this movie you can watch our non-spoiler
review spoiler for that non-spoiler we
pretty much agreed on like a 3.75 out of
5 I think this is a really enjoyable
film I want to make that flat out clear
because I'm watching so many YouTube
reviews everyone's like it's okay it
kind of feels like a lot of people are
really talking down yeah and I'm gonna
go out there and tell you guys I think
it's a wildly enjoyable felt I had so
much fun and it made me happy it is so
much fun I can always kind of see where
people are coming from people are being
a little too critical of the film there
are issues I agree with and walk away
thinking about that almost none of the
issues with this movie hampered my
enjoyment and my girl towards like will
hopping into spoilers in just a second I
just want to remind everyone this one
has a very simple intent yeah and if you
know the first and man and if you seen
the [ __ ] trailers or the movie it has
a very simple intention which is make
you laugh dazzle you with some action
scenes it's that simple the movie gives
you that it's exactly what you would you
want from it we're gonna go into some
spoilers on things that are issues that
I had with the
film sure it seems like the thing that
really lowers the bar for a lot of
people are the issues they think about
but I think the pros in this film
greatly outweigh so I just want to first
thought to encourage you guys if you
want you to spoilers if you do it with
that well I think turning off now I walk
it out people to watch this movie
because I think it's a very very very
fun movie there are surprises in how
this movie deals with certain things
that might be a little getting used to
if you're not yeah because I mean that's
something that struck me about this
movie first and foremost is like you go
in expecting like aa ghost is gonna be
like the villain part of what surprised
me and part of what I appreciated
overall is the movie doesn't have like a
central villain eventually motely said
it best actually we have opponents but
not necessarily villain yeah I kind of
view them as obstacles and and I think
in circumstances rubbing up against each
other creating tensions I don't like
that ant-man by the end of it feels so
much like a supporting character in a
film that starts off in a way where it
seems like he is the main lead and then
by the end of it you're like yeah this
movie could this franchise continuing
without him for as much as the
motivation gets him to becoming ant-man
yeah that point it seems like he is kind
of just part of the team right when the
movie was done and we were talking in
the group was I didn't like that he
seemed kind of dumb in this film I think
in the first movie he's super smart it's
like that's why he said I need you to
believe he's a pretty good thief yeah
cuz he's very clever but he figures I
had to get into that bulk he's
improvising on the spot and here you
never really get that Paul Rudd moment
here but you get so much funny stuff
with Scott laying in this movie yeah I
mean he you know you do join him on
house arrest he is kind of sad out of
the game in all respects when we find
him in this movie and he's not an
unnecessary character the whole reason
they bring him back is because of his
connection to Janet in the quantum realm
scene that I just thought it was so
funny that could have gone for like okay
jokes but didn't was what Janet's like
speaking through him and he has no idea
to know
and he's playing it's super sincere and
I like how Michael Douglas and imagining
Lily they do the whole like what the
hell but they eventually feel like
they're just talking to Janet yeah like
holding his hand
Laura comes back in the room he's like
what's going on guys Walton Goggins is
character I do find his character
unnecessary in the movie it's in some
ways it seemed like the movie was trying
to shift into him being the actual
villain of the film but I got problems
with that because a there's no threat
really about him other than you're kind
of an inconvenience but anytime they
even have the building when it's in a
miniature size ya gonna do real damage
to this doors I gotta be a prop for them
to get that building the fact that none
of his involvement has anything to do
with the actual threat of the movie
which is the clock the clock to get
Janet Van Dyne out of the quantum realm
that's the threat time is the enemy in
the film he has no involvement of that
if anything he just feels like an
inconvenient plotline yeah it's like it
makes sense they might be tangling with
a guy like this is just in the overall
context of the movie or like it kind of
feels non-essential when everything else
is taken into consideration the logic
checks out on Walton Goggins only have
you find a seedy guy who'll give you a
part I'm sure you'd be a business that
would go sour with that guy like it's a
choice that works it's just not like
tied into the movie you know and and
they kind of goes goes with ghosts I
don't really like the writing of ghosts
I kind of think it's bland I think John
Kramer who can of John came and does
what she can to elevate the role cuz you
know I get her character she's always in
a constant state of pain so you do
sympathize for her in that department if
anything the highlight for me was
Laurence Fishburne yeah this is dr. bill
Foster when dr. bill foster first shows
up I like the chemistry the history
established with Hank Pym I thought that
was all very fun and then when he shows
up in the same room as Ghost
they toy with you in a fun way that's
more interesting than your kind used to
with these movies for me I was like oh
no he's a bad guy and then as the
further you get you're like okay he's
not exactly bad he's
another person trying to help out
somebody affected by these weird super
circumstances I thought his character
actually added to her character you kind
of have a father-daughter thing formed
that's happened with them you see the
scene where they meet where Laurence
Fishburne it's 20 years ago and yet he
looks younger than he did in the matrix
which was five years ago we see what
they mean when it there is kind of a
surrogate father the relationship that
has developed with them and I really did
like the way Laurence Fishburne his
character was handled in the film where
whatever it could have been on bad guy
territory if anything he's the one you
know reeling her back going we shouldn't
go this far oh speaking of little girls
I don't want to do that you know I
really care about you and even he starts
to get to a point of maybe Janet can
help you out in a whole finale of the
car chase scene which was choreographed
excellently
I couldn't help but sometimes get
annoyed ghost is feeling rather
inconvenient to this plot I get it your
obstacle getting in the way cuz time is
the enemy you got to keep that in my
time is the enemy they got to get to
Janet by a certain time Michael Douglas
is inside the quantum realm as the car
chase is going on it gets that point of
like oh my gosh ghosts Walton Goggins
just get out of the way for a second
would you and I don't know if it's in a
good annoyance or a bad annoyance yeah
it's the weird nebulous middle zone
between stakes and frustration which are
yeah I guess that depends on you they
don't feel like real threats
I feel like this movie could have
benefited off a real villainous threat I
feel like one of them could have been
especially when you have two opponents
two obstacles because that's where you
get stakes like in a movie yeah I'm kind
of torn on that because part of me does
appreciate what it does to keep the
consistency of the scope I kind of like
that ant-man both of these movies have
established a scope that is a little
more down-to-earth it is a little less
Oh total destruction and death and all
that like I kind of like the stakes are
smaller I do kind of feel like there
could have been maybe something a little
bit more effective in the way they
handled the stakes or handled the
opposition I don't really exactly know
how to put my finger on that and some
people have pitched the idea of
consolidating character
because yeah I guess you it seems like
you have too many things standing in the
way they are sort of like ah now you and
your wringing your hands a lot I think
if you cut out Walton Goggins storyline
enhanced more of ghost storyline we
probably could have had a better movie
and it still could have been the thing
where she's not a super villain but her
effect would have been more felt I think
it's weird it's like I like the idea of
how they went about this and there's
something you know in it that doesn't
know 100% click I guess besides that
there's some neat stuff handled there
how'd you feel about Michelle Pfeiffer
coming out of the quantum realm and then
solving the ghost problem for us
[ __ ] harpy yeah there were a number of
transitions I mean one of my few
complaints about this movie there are a
number of transitions that felt very
fast and that was definitely one of them
she just comes right out the ship and is
like oh let me take a look at you with
all the speculation - before the movie
about like what's being in the quantum
realm for all this time gonna do to her
mind you know I know there are different
versions of the comics where she comes
back and she's not right kind of
skipping past ought to be like no she's
fine here we got a little odd for me
like there's a little bit of stunting in
that moment I feel like where it ends up
I did enjoy I thought when they finally
connected Hank Pym and and Janet yeah
when they finally connected I felt that
moment to be rewarding it was all the
scenes after her I feel like everyone's
is now used to that she's back it's been
30 years the weight of her return should
be more like a massive cathartic moment
yeah missing that moment and more of a
mystery element to who she is now as
opposed to oh you're angels because it
doesn't even feel like they're setting
it up for a future installment really I
mean we gotta get her back
other than the healing thing that's set
up or something for the future I guess
it doesn't really feel like who she is
and unravelling more of who she's become
is being set up yeah it kind of just
seems like a God in some way yeah yeah
for us however wonderful a human being
is that character might be your like you
also didn't spend a good significant
amount of your life in the quantum we
should be crazy yeah you should be like
freakin nuts now
yeah and then of course you know there's
the mid-credits scene I feel like people
love this mid-credits scene I like what
it does with ant-man
I think that's a great setup for him to
be set up for the next Avengers movie
where he's just like that's a scary
scenario for him
that's a very scary scenario I kind of
hated that we went on this giant ass
adventure yeah with the wasp Hank Pym
and we just got Janet Van Dyne back and
then it kind of seems like you're
setting up Janet Van Dyne to play an
integral role maybe for the next
Avengers movie they just go to us it's
like some people I think it's cool
because of infinity war tie-in but then
when I think of it as a plot I'm kind of
annoyed contextually and I don't know if
this would have worked but I think it
would have been cooler or more
interesting if Janet had been spared and
and Hank and and hope this that would
have been fine yeah I think honestly I
would have been cool with that I would
have been way cool with that because
then you've got at least still two
people but you know the new characters
God is know very well and then sky you
know yeah which would get him out of the
quantum realm pretty easily but at the
same time just for the Sinister stakes
of that it's one thing to have him
trapped in there and I get why that's
the choice they went with but in terms
of characters I thought it might have
been more interesting now oh the
post-credits scene I told everyone in
the car I'm like I think the mid-credits
scene is gonna be an affinity we're
tired and then the post-credits scene
will be a funny thing cheeky sure enough
that's how it went down
yeah a fortunate part is the
post-credits scene is in the [ __ ]
trailer well you see it multiple times
in the actual movie itself yeah drumming
and I'm like yeah I like that joke we
couldn't do something new for this no
yeah I smoked an like Howard the Duck
this again did you just move us a
deleted scene to thin yeah I mean you
know it's cute yeah it serves his
purpose I wasn't like I've said about it
cuz it's just yeah it's that weird thing
of like this gag I've seen the only
thing that's different now is the ant
doesn't quite realize that the whole
world is going to [ __ ] around yeah yeah
you know because you see like there's on
the TV you know like there's a news
report
and that was the thing about this movie
to where people were speculating and
there was lots of hype about like oh and
man the watch gonna reveal stuff about
infinity war I'm like it doesn't reveal
anything
well that's the thing goes a lot of the
time though Marvel's great at that I
think that's what infinity war
especially woke me to was there's a lot
in there that is paid off that I didn't
realize was really being set up in Prior
movies like really there was like little
things ever never set up for infinity
war some stuff is burying your face and
supporting former installment and then
some stuff was so subtle that you're
that when you go back and watch the
movies you're like oh yeah and maybe
they're doing that here and we just
don't fully realize that maybe this
quantum realm stuff is all a big setup
that is that go that ties into it who
know either way though I think this film
is full laughs it's so great action in
it really really think about what we do
we only touched on like three to four
things yeah it's not a movie without
some issues but yeah the overall viewing
experience and its place in the MCU I
had a total blast I had total blast
I loved all that stuff with Paul Rudd in
the school like I think that the action
was enhanced I think this is more
confident direction I do and most people
I'm hearing safer they prefer the first
ant-man I personally do prefer this one
I think it's a more solid film I like
the adventure like even those complaints
aside because the thing is like watching
the movie with those things in mind I'm
not grumpy about them yeah these
complaints come back to the villain and
I'll give you points for trying to do
something different and interesting with
your story structure as opposed to just
yeah me what I know yeah anyway guys
what were your favorite moments or
biggest complaints about a man and the
wasps put in the comments below John
don't be pooping I am whooping all to
check us out on patreon so like TV show
reactions weekly Q&A x' would love to
have you become a patron oject today